breath of the wild is a pretty wild game
I mean even for a Zelda title this game
has giant luminescent flying dragons
demon-possessed statues malicious goop
and of course ancient war machines that
are rather proficient in killing you but
of all the mysterious technology and
magic like the strange bloody skies that
bring back the dead
one little side piece of the game has
always captivated people's attentions
and that would be the Lord of the
mountain Satori mountain to be precise
and if you don't know who or what or
where I'm talking about allow me to
remind you if you've ever been riding
around gliding or otherwise adventuring
in the western portion of the wide wide
world of Hyrule chances are you've
looked to the West at some point and
seen a strangely peaked mountain with
what looks like a green glowing spire on
top what in the world you probably asked
yourself as you decided to creep up the
mountain and figure out just what this
alien light was coming from eventually
you stumbled across him the Lord of the
mountain
also known as Satori this horse like owl
like flashlight like being stands amidst
a gazillion blue peas which all bear
some pretty striking resemblances to
Satori what with the same glowing colour
heads in all but that aside I want to
focus on who or what exactly the fabled
Lord of the mountain really is as well
as what its backstory might be as you've
probably already heard the best theory
out there in my opinion is that it was
created in honor of the late Satoru
Iwata hence the similar name who
unfortunately passed away before breath
of the wild was released now this theory
is heartwarming and probably even true
but there's more to the story you see
breath the wild may be full of shoutouts
and references to other games and
commentaries on the zelda community but
that doesn't mean these references and
easter eggs are all non canon the lord
of the mountain has you know a mountain
named after it is referenced by an NPC
and is even recognized by stable masters
meaning it has a canon influence on the
world of breath of the wild well since
it's a Canon being that actually exists
in breath of wild lore that means we
have to take what we know about it in
game seriously like the fact that it's
in game description details that legends
say it used to be a sage who died on the
lands that now protects a
now any fan of the Zelda franchise worth
their salt knows that Zelda and sages go
hand in hand the seven sages from
ocarina of time the two sages from Wind
Waker seven sages from a Link to the
Past and six from Twilight Princess at
cetera at Sega and Zelda games tend to
take their sages very seriously so
firstly in order to speculate on what
the Lord of the mountains backstory
might be let's first define what exactly
a Zelda game means by sage according to
real world classical philosophy a sage
is a person who has obtained a lot of
wisdom they're even called wise men in a
Link to the Past but their real purposes
differ from game to game
sometimes they're useful in sealing away
Ganon and sometimes they're useful in
restoring power to the master sword and
other times they try to stab Ganondorf
in the gut but each time they make an
appearance they represent an element and
are normally a member of a race of
people who complement said element but
this isn't always the case as in a Link
to the Past in Twilight Princess they're
all of the same race of just featureless
people so in summary a sage in zelda
lore is simply an individual who was
normally a part of a group that served
some divine purpose for the goddesses
yep that's basically it so now back to
the lord of the mountain Satori was a
sage that much is known from its in-game
description it's also stated that it
died on the land it now protects and I'd
wager it's pretty safe to assume this
land that it died on is the Satori
Mountain what would the name and it
being the only place Tottori appears in
the entire game at all as fellow zelda
youtuber Croton very expertly analyzes
in his video covering the Satori
Mountain significance which of course
I'll link to in the description below
because to be honest I don't think
anybody could do a better job at
exploring the mountains geographical and
natural characteristics then he already
did we can fairly safely assume that
Satori in life was a protector of the
animals of the world who lived and died
on the mountain the reasoning behind
these assumptions is that on nights when
Satori appears the area is littered with
animals that have come to see the Lord
of the mountain and when speaking to a
certain NPC hunter named quince from
another part of the world who previously
had attempted to hunt the animals that
appeared on Satori mountain on one of
these nights it's revealed that the Lord
of the mountain was allegedly about to
attack the hunter when he was saved at
the last moment by his new best friend
we can only assume Satori was going to
attack him because the hunter was there
to harm the animal populace by hunting
them now combine this information with
the fact that there are no animal pens
or cages on the mountain that we see in
other parts of the world and we can come
to the safe assumption that Satori in
life was a protector of wildlife and was
revived to do the same in death now on
to the next question how exactly did the
Lord of the mountain die and here's
where I'm going to start speculating
like crazy based off of the information
we can find in-game so please let me
know what you think and if you agree or
feel differently after listening to what
I've come up with among the animals and
plants and strange glowing rabbits that
appear on the mountain we do find some
enemies that appear at night Staal
enemies there is a stall knocks and
several other enemies like stall collins
dawn maudlin and stall is all those that
are present on the mountain I feel like
that's incredibly significant in the
Lord of the mountains backstory and
here's why those are dead enemies as in
not alive in present day as in enemies
from some time past that are being
reanimated most likely at the points
where they died what if this means that
when calamity Ganon and his forces swept
Hyrule a hundred years ago Satori
protected the mountain from the forces
of calamities evil for as long as he
could until Ganon sent a venn living
super soldier hynek's and other monster
foot soldiers to a soul to the mountain
ultimately killing Satori he was a sage
in life which means he may have had
powers or other means that he used to
defend the animals on the mountain
whatever Satori did before he died was
obviously significant enough to get him
reborn eternally as a protective spirit
watching over the nature of the mountain
with the meticulously positioned
powerful stoll enemies I feel like it's
a very safe assumption that Satori
defeated those enemies before ultimately
dying on the land he protected it's also
important to note that on nights when
Satori appears the staal enemies do not
perhaps signifying their defeat at the
hands or rather the hooves of the Lord
of the mountain and you know speaking of
when Satori appears isn't it a little
bit strange that it isn't every day
why does Satori only appear every now
and then well what if something has to
happen for him to appear again to
continue my speculation rant I think a
big clue to the only so often
appearances of the Lord of the mountain
can be found from what surrounds him
when he does appear you see when Satori
materializes in the mountain pool not
only is there an abundance of animal
life on the mountain but specifically
surrounding the pool that Satori appears
in is an army of little blue rabbits
also known as blue peace now why are
they there and have you ever wondered
what their entire deal is well let's
think about it for a second not only do
they look very similar to Satori with
similar antlers and heads and the exact
same tone of luminescent green glowing
from their bodies but blue peas are
found all over Hyrule and are obsessed
with rupees hence their similar name
they congregate around the Lord of the
mountain when he appears and dispersed
when he isn't there you know how the
great fairies in the game have to
receive an offering of rupees to be
revived well and I'm sure you can guess
where I'm going with this what if the
Lord of the mountain requires an
offering of rupees to appear what if the
eternal cycle of the Lord of the
mountains reincarnation involves blue
peas going out into the world and
retrieving rupees to bring back to his
resurrection pool so that he can then
return to life and use his power to
cleanse the mountain of evil as many
times as he needs to and could this also
explain why we no longer see rupees in
grass a breath of the wild like we used
to in almost every other Zelda game
because blue peas are taking them to
revive Satori or am I just crazy
let me know in a comment below and
quickly now before I wrap up the video I
wanted to cover the matter of which sage
Satori used to be or even still is to be
honest I don't think this question is
all that important sages don't
necessarily have to represent the same
six elements every time of forest fire
water shadow spirit and light just look
at the Wind Waker which just randomly
introduced earth and wind after the game
already acknowledges the original six
sages could it be that what a sage
represents isn't really all that
important
now if Satori was one of these sages an
argument could be made that he was the
sage of light since rara a previous and
very well known sage of light was
represented by an owl and Satori and his
blue peas have owl heads but this could
also just be a picture of Satori's
watchful nature which owls are known to
represent you can also make an argument
that Satori is the sage of the forest
for obvious nature-loving reasons or
that he's the new sage of animals or
rupees or literally anything else it
for this reason that I don't think what
sages represent is important but rather
what they do that matters the most the
Lord of the mountain was and is an
eternal protector of the wildlife upon
Satori mountain the lone sage of legend
and to be honest with you that's enough
for me but what do you guys think did
the Lord of the mountain die battling
Ganon's monsters or something else and
is he reincarnated by his blue peas to
cleanse the mountain over and over again
for all eternity or something else let
me know what you think in a comment
below also if you enjoyed the video
please be sure to like it up to get it
moving around on YouTube also also
subscribe if you haven't already with
that Bela Khan for much more juicy
Nintendo stuffs to come as always huge
thank you to my amazing patrons of which
I have two more editions welcome to
carry me land Tim and thank you so much
for choosing to support the channel if
you're interested in getting your name
up here at the end of each of my videos
feel free to check out the link in the
description below for more info also
down there are links to my social media
pages so please be sure to stop by and
say hi
that's all I've gotten this one so do me
a huge favor and have a great rest of
your day
this is Masum panda bandits signing out
peace
[Music]